well liberals were one and one
at the supreme court this week they won
a big money obamacare was
uh upheld this is the third
this is the third time it has survived
an attempt to kill it
it's the 50 cent of progressive
legislation it's
but
on the other side of the legend the
court sided with the catholic church
big surprise most of the courts
catholics
they sided with the church who believe
it is their right
not to work with gay parents
to help adopt children george says their
position has always been very plain if
children want to be around gay adults
they can become altar boys
oh i kid the church always with love
and of course the big
the big international news we finally
had our summit with
putin and biden they met in geneva
switzerland
did you see that this week they
switzerland
[Applause]
they wanted it to be in switzerland they
needed some place that doesn't pick a
side between the u.s and russia and
mar-a-lago was booked
but uh you know
it was good to see the american
president siding with america that was a
change
and uh it was
you know and also these summits you
never know what really is said in the
room as it should be
but the pictures it's like the tabloids
the pictures tell the story
they can [ __ ] whatever they want you
look at the pictures you could tell this
was tense
you saw that picture of putin and biden
look like the married couple who had a
fight in the car on the way over
and then of course they all have a press
conference afterwards putin i mean
imagine negotiating with this guy
this is what putin said i'm not making
this up he said there is no happiness in
life
only a mirage of it on the horizon
which i was going to jump all over and
then i remember that was the theme of
this year's oscars
so who am i to talk
there is no happiness just mirage on the
horizon
[Applause]
lovely guy anyway um
so anyway putin but biden gets back the
republicans while he was overseas were
very respectful i'm kidding of course
they [ __ ] all over everything they
always forget their own rule about the
president big overseas
he gets back 13 house republicans signed
a letter
today demanding that biden take a
cognitive
fitness test
biden yes he oh he imagines he's
president because he got the most votes
yeah one they want to know is iq
iq iq is what marge retailer green says
when you ask her who are you
thank you
you